can you can you pull up uh
[ __ ] like uh
uh uh uh cost of college tuition
over the years right now is looking at
colleges because because when we when we
look at the cost of college tuition i'll
just trigger matter right now
think about that because when you look
at the cost of college tuition
um
can you go to twitter the one i posted
where
uh i showed the numbers of what's
happened to cost of college tuition if
you go a little lower you'll say that's
just i put up a bar but here's here's
what happens with
how cost of living has increased when it
comes down to college debt they're
talking about writing off the debt
rights okay you know just
forgive everybody when it comes down to
college then okay
in the college debt situation what what
individuals are involved let's go
through it number one is the institution
which is what the actual
college right
two is the student who's involved in
that relationship three
is the parent
who's involved in that relationship
uh four is the government that's
involved in that relationship and then
let's put lender there it could be the
same but it's involved in a relationship
right
so we have what we have the institution
at the top we have the student the
parent
the government and the lender right if i
said it correctly right those five
people that are involved okay
so
college used to be very cheap wasn't
that expensive right if you look at that
right there
that's the college tuition inflation
since 1980 according to cpi actual
inflation
college tuition is up 11.84
inflation is only up 228. who the hell
let these guys do this
now if you look at this 220 versus 1184
go go a little bit lower on the tweet by
the way go a little bit lower on the
tweet just get back and go to the
following stuff that i say below yeah so
uh average salary in 1980 was 21 200.
average salary in 2021 is 51 480.
it's up only 142
yet college tuition is up 1184
how am i supposed to keep up as a parent
right so so when did this change here's
how it changed you ready folks here's
how it changed
the moment
the government said we'll help colleges
out with your student loans
it became a business
colleges and the government teamed up
together then colleges had
no limitations on what they could charge
they said we're going to charge this
much no problem we'll lend it out we're
going to charge you no problem we'll let
them out and the government said hey you
can't write off your student loan you
have to pay for it but i can write off
all the other debt yeah so you inside so
you were against slavery now you just
turned me into slave what happened there
why are you doing that to me i can't pay
these payments oh but it's for the good
of your future because a degree is going
to change your life oh really most
people who get a degree don't even work
a job that has to do anything with that
degree what the hell do you mean it's
for the better me for me to get so they
created a monopoly for colleges colleges
took advantage of that because colleges
are the ultimate capitalist by the way
no write-off tax advantages they have
the biggest loophole in america
harvard's sitting on 40 billion dollars
of cash endowment they can literally for
the next hundred years not take a penny
from their students and they will still
have money a hundred years from now with
the amount of money that they got in the
bank but what do we do who paid the
price you know who paid the price
you know who paid the price
not the institution they won
not the lender they won not the
government they got reelected you know
paid the price the parent and the
student that's right
and over and over and so when they're
like we should forgive the debt why
forgive the debt why put the write off
on everybody else we should we should
forgive it no no
before we forgive it i'm open to
forgiveness
but step number one
let's go get colleges to kind of catch
back up to cpi 228 which means to be at
228 you know what the average college
you know annual like you know what's the
annual tuition for harvard right now 55
grand 56 grand more than that harvard
would need to come down to 11 000
and then let's forgive it do you know
what i'm saying so why don't we bring it
back down to harvard's what it's it's
academics 51 000 without financial aid
forty nine thousand dollars a year
earlier one room and board and other
freeze brings it up to seventy four
thousand dollars and during covet they
asked hey since you're doing everything
on zoom for the degree can you lower the
price what did harvard say nope same
exact price
now you're telling me that capitalists
are greedy i don't see anybody more
greedy than these college institutions i
think you're absolutely right
i got a full tuition scholarship to the
boston conservatory
and i had to come up my own room and
board i worked studied my grandfather
helped me out a couple hundred bucks
here and there
um
but that was my option it was either
scholarship or no college
i just paid off my 40 000 in student
debt a year ago no [ __ ] that was the
last thing i had i paid off my time
share in like three years i paid off all
the other things but i just kept that
college decision what year did you
graduate 95.
so that's almost 27 years 20 400 a month
going to sallie mae
well on average it takes 18 to 20 years
to pay off student debt that's the hour
i deferred from time to time okay well
there you're starting out yeah that
brought it way up but yeah i mean it's
insane it talk it is just one of these
bills and it is the entree into the
middle class that said however i think
we're gonna see a massive backlash i
think well first of all a lot a lot of
kids are gonna look at the situation
today they're kids with i know a kid in
my town has got a 4.68 gpa couldn't get
in any of the schools she applied to
it's insane how's that possible well
there's a whole like northeast bias now
um there's colleges are it's it's a big
story new york times ran a big thing
about it um now it sounds like wow you
couldn't get into your school you got to
go to a lesser school and to an extent
they're right and you could argue
arguments have been made that going into
a lesser school is better for you like
if you go to harvard as a doctor you're
in there with the best damn doctor so
you come out as like fourth best doctor
you're you're not happy you go to ithaca
college you know you're the best doctor
there you have a great life great career
because you were the best doctor
yeah yeah so i think we're going to see
a lot of that i think colleges the
backlash is going to be real we're
letting a lot of more international
students too that's a big part of it um
but also you have now this whole
generation being raised on instagram
learning you can become a millionaire
without having to go to college correct
you know there's all these
hacks these these financial hacks these
career hacks so is it more on the
student or is it more on the parent
because when i was 17 18 years old
applying for college dude i couldn't
tell you what the hell i wanted to do
with my life i couldn't tell you why i
wanted to go to college it's just that i
just knew that it was
almost robotically the correct thing to
do was to go to college and it is to get
a middle-class job but today you can go
to a state school for almost free or
free a lot of states now have programs
where if you go to school and it's in
community college state college
it is free there are state programs that
will the loan forgiveness is already
happening at the state level so
ultimately what we're not talking about
is the concept of college or the concept
of a higher education i think that's
invaluable i think that's important not
necessarily for your for your iq but
certainly for your eq i think i learned
more about
um networking and who to hang out with
and who's got their thing going on and
who to hang out with and who to maybe
invite to the parties like i think i
learned more of that in college than i
did
in a certain class or two but ultimately
what we're talking about is roi return
on your investment of the amount of debt
or the amount of uh cost that you're
paying for college if you can get it for
free i think it's a no-brainer would you
disagree
yeah exactly so it's not free and just
to clarify what adam said really quick
is the taxpayer should pay for you to go
to school
not to improve your intelligence or
learn anything new but so you can party
and learn how to network and get a
little check off that says you went to
college
it just well if you're holding the
colleges accountable for providing
education that you're supposed to
provide then you know you could argue
that it's for the betterment of society
in general but that gets to you know the
evil word socialism which we can't utter
you know what i mean but again the
colleges aren't teaching kids what
they're supposed to do that's learning
right yeah you've seen the stats where
it's the the education levels easier and
easier and easier to pass schools now
right every at almost every grade
they're catering to the students not the
not the needs like i i think there's
everything wrong not everything but so
much wrong with the idea that you have
to go to college to to make yourself in
life it's like no dude go learn a trade
well thank you guys
like you say there's hacks you can start
your own business hell look how many
people are millionaires on only fans
like they're entrepreneurs i don't agree
with genetics
everybody has to go to college to make
it in life is absurd and to matt's point
you are seeing a huge backlash to this i
mean people are realizing that college
is a scam i mean it's just not worth it
70 is a waste of time 30 stem or if
you've got a sports scholarship go
forward but 70 of it is a is a waste of
time uh to go to college you know if you
and a few the schools right now it's
crazy you know in our community a lot of
these guys are guys that have money
and a lot of them are banking on
vanderbilt over any of the
you know
ivy leagues it's like vanderbilt is
where they're looking i'm like
vanderbilt interesting
so penn comes up vanderbilt comes up
duke comes up some of these guys come up
uh
but some of these guys that are ivy
league in the direction they're going
yeah i think
i think this whole system is broken when
it comes down to college and if we want
to write off the college debt i'm fully
for it but let's first lower the tuition
by 80 percent then let's write that and
by the way i'll pay for increase my
taxes a little bit but first let's
change that from fifty one thousand
dollars to harvard at eleven thousand
dollars right let them also pay a little
bit of the price because they're
breaking the backs of parents that are
busting their ass two three four jobs to
be able to say i sent my son to a good
school and i paid for it no bro it
shouldn't be that much money that should
be eleven thousand dollars so if you
like this clip and you wanna watch
another one click right here and if you
wanna watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]